America is home to the greatest
scientists, the most advanced weaponry,
and that's just technology. Propaganda
means that America controls information
space. It controls the internet. It
controls the world's most powerful
media, the New York Times, CNN, BBC. It
controls YouTube. It controls Google. It
controls information landscape. America
can control the discourse. It can
control how you think about the world.
That's propaganda.
>> You know, it was super eye opening
yesterday. I was speaking to that
American soldier and he didn't know why
he was going into war. And I said,
"Wait, why are you doing this war?" And
he said, "Well, I want to protect
America." I'm like, "Well, they just
said Iran did not pose an imminent
threat to America. They just said that."
I didn't I didn't know. Why would you
not look this up before giving your life
to a cause?
>> That's one problem. Propaganda. You
would think that, oh, America can
control the debate. Therefore, that's a
huge advantage. It's actually not an
advantage, guys. The reason why is that
in order for innovation and resilience
to happen, you you need to have open
debate, right? Opinions.
>> This is happening right now. So many of
these major voices, they won't engage in
dialogue. A lot of them, maybe they're
not aware, but they do want to push
things that are lies and are propaganda
and are untrue.
>> You're not allowed to point out that
this war is stupid. But if you control
the information landscape, what you can
do is censor.
And that's what America's doing right
now. They're telling people to shut up
and obey.
>> Let's get into it. The law of asymmetry.
>> We continue our discussion of the US
Iran war that is happening right now.
So um as you know I made a prediction
that the United States will lose this
war and last
a guy is serious about you.
>> How do you tell a are you a woman asking
for like marriage advice? What is that
question? Um it's going to be really
obserious
about you then he's probably not serious
about you of the military and strategic
position. And today we're going to
provide some theoretical framework for
how to understand how this war will
progress and why ultimately I believe
the United States will lose this war.
>> Jang gang.
>> Today I present to you a very important
idea in game theory. And once you
understand this idea, you understand why
things will turn out the way they do.
Okay? It's called the law of asymmetry.
>> Asymmetry.
>> Law of asymmetry.
All this is saying is that
>> the United States and Iran are not
peers. They're not equals. United States
is far stronger.
>> Don't come to Canada. We're already
cooked here. You guys need to pull
through.
>> Yeah, I'm good off Canada, bro. Thanks,
Son. But, uh, yeah, they too much H1Bs
going on.
>> And we should expect the United States
to overwhelm and destroy Iran really
easily.
>> Look at rage baiting saying pre-watch.
Why would I pre-watch a lecture first
off? Second off, it literally dropped 1
hour ago, 3 hours ago. I've been there.
>> Well, as states that that's usually not
the case. It's usually underdog that has
the advantage.
And we see this from history all the
time. Okay. So, when a Persian
hope you look into it yourself,
>> Kam was fighting ISIS. Oh my god.
>> TTS $50. This is why this is why I put
the TCS to 50.
>> 90 BC invaded mainland Greece against
Athens and Sparta.
>> Persia at this at that time was the
first world empire. It had infinite
resources, infinite manpower, infinite
wealth and it lost to the Greeks not
once but twice. And then the Macedonians
under the Greek and they were like a
tribal army, not a very large army. They
were able to go into Persia and Persia
at the time was basically most of
Eurasia and conquered it in about 10
years time. The Romans started off as a
tribal people which then built the
Mediterranean Empire.
Then you have the Aztecs, you have so
the Vikings. So this happens a lot in
human history. a people in the
borderlands, a tribe, a small ethnicity
are able to conquer a great empire. And
the law of asymmetry tells us why. Okay.
So, I'm going to go over uh very slowly
in detail how this law of symmetry
asymmetry works. All right. So, um let's
look at an empire.
And there are three major advantages to
an empire. I'm
>> not beefing with mine,
>> right? The first is mass.
>> Lock in y'all. Lock in. Lock in.
This just means that they have a lot of
people. Okay, they also have an infinite
amount of people. United States has a
population of about 350 million people.
But remember, the United States can also
draw on the populations of its allies,
which includes the five eyes, the
angles, but also includes Europe. It
also includes uh East Asia, South Korea,
Japan, basically wherever the Americans
have military base, right? So most of
the world are either allies of the
United States or vassels of United
States. So organization can basically
draw on in billions and billions of
people for its wars. Okay. So it's mass.
Second is idea of organization.
Organization just means a hierarchy of
bureaucracy
scientific technology. Okay? Science and
technology
which leads to the most advanced
weaponry. Okay? Think about the United
States, how they fight this war. They
have these satellites that provide for
precision targeting. They have these um
airplanes, these B2 bombers, F-15s that
are the most advanced um weaponry ever
in human history. Okay, so organization.
And the last great strength of the
empire is that of death.
Death is the idea that because your
people are infinite, because your
organization is so strong, because your
resources are so vast, you can afford to
lose many, many wars. Okay? It's not a
big deal. United States loses this war
in Iran. If they want to go back, they
can go back with even more soldiers,
even more um weaponry because their
wealth is infinite
>> like Vietnam. Okay, so these are the
three major advantages of an empire. And
in theory, because of these advantages,
an empire should be invincible and
eternal. But we know for a fact that all
empires fall and they fall very very
hard. And quite honestly, they don't
last a very long time. Maybe 20 years,
maybe 300 years for most empires. That's
not a very long time.
So we need to better understand what's
going on. Okay. Why is it that an empire
with these vast resources they all fall
in 20 years, 20 years? Okay. All right.
>> So um
>> what we need to understand is that all
these advantages are ultimately
disadvantages. No long term. All right.
So let let me explain what I mean. Matt,
you have a lot of people. Okay. When you
have a lot of people, you create a lot
of inequality.
and immigrants, right?
>> Why? Because there's competition for
resources. There's too many people,
okay? And this often leads to debt and
slavery.
And as a result, your people become
complacent, lazy, indifferent. They're
competing against each other. They
really don't like the government. Okay?
So, they're not that really that
motivated to do anything to work or to
fight wars, but especially to fight
wars. So this mass looks like it looks
like an advantage in the beginning over
time it becomes a disadvantage right
organization
um means an elite the problem with this
is that over time the elite become
parasites.
Why? Because the way the way they make
their money is through rent seeking.
Rentiging just means that you have power
and you seek to monetize your power by
exploiting the mass.
All right? So basically landlords are a
classic type of renting elite and so
they
work but they make a lot of money
because they own the land because they
control all the resources because they
control all the capital and that forces
the mass to go into slavery to go into
debt which is what's happening in
America today. The problem with this is
that everyone everyone wants to be part
of the elite and there are too many
elite over time. Okay. So even though
you have elite have many many kids the
uh power is that zero sum games a
hierarchy and so this leads to the idea
of elite over production. Okay elite
overprouction
this is a term um coined by the
historian Peter Turchin. Okay. And his
theory is that you have turmoil, you
have wars, for example, the French
revolution, for example, uh the fall
woman republic because there's too many
elite and they start wars to gain power
for themselves. Okay? So this
organization, this elite leads to
basically factionalism or infighting.
And that's what's happening in America
today where the Democrats and the
Republicans they hate each other. They
refuse to get along.
>> It leads to political polarization.
Okay. So another saying this is that an
empire over time becomes insular. They
don't care about what happens outside
the world. All they care about is what
happens in Washington DC. And as a
result um they make a lot of stupid
mistakes. Okay. All right. The last
thing is death. Okay. The problem with
death is that if there are no
consequences to your actions, you become
arrogant, you become lazy,
uh, and you become incompetent. Okay,
>> I think Pete Hex is the perfect example
of death depth right now. The way he
bragging and flexing epic fury, you
know, bragging about bombing cities like
Tran indiscriminately, that is a good
example of thinking that there's not
going to be any consequences to your
actions
>> because you don't care. It doesn't
really matter. This leads to the idea of
hubris.
>> Hubris is a word.
>> Hubris is just blindness to your own
arrogance. A violent arrogance that
makes you make mistakes, but you don't
recognize your mistakes and you keep on
repeating the same mistakes over and
over again. Right? So yes, it seems like
the empire is invisible, but if you
actually think about it, think about
this. The empire its advantages becomes
over time its disadvantages which which
will lead ultimately to its downfall.
Okay. So the mass leads to inequality.
The organization leads over production
which leads to factionalism and death
leads to hubris. That's why an empire
must fall over time. But an empire
cannot fall by itself. It needs an enemy
that forces it to collapse.
>> Okay? And so what happens is that an
enemy will emerge that will um overwhelm
the empire because it is able to take
advantage of the weaknesses of the
empire. All right? And so what are the
weaknesses of this empire? Well, the
first major weakness of this empire is
that the people aren't really motivated.
So if you as people are really
motivated, you have a huge advantage.
Okay, we call this energy.
>> Who has motivation right now and who
doesn't? Steer after the assassination
of Hamemeni.
All right now as an organ as an empire
you become insular. You refuse to omit
your mistakes. You refuse to learn from
others. Well, if you are willing to omit
your mistakes, if you're willing to
learn, if you're willing to um promote
the best and brightest, if you're
willing to meritocratic, you have a huge
advantage. Okay. And so this his hand is
getting worse. What is that? What does
that even say? What does that say?
>> Openness.
The last idea is this. An empire is
fractured. So if you're able to m
maintain cohesion,
cohesion,
>> if people are able to remain united, if
they're able to have,
>> this says energy.
This says energy.
What
>> purpose? They'll be strong. Okay.
So if an enemy of the empire emerges
with these three qualities, energy,
openness and cohesion, this enemy will
defeat the empire.
Does that make sense? Okay. So what I
want you to focus on as you follow the
news in this war between United States
and Iran is ask yourself a question.
Will Iran become an energetic, open and
cohesive society? Because if it does, it
will become invincible.
The empire won't change because of
hubris. It's too static. It's too
stagnant. It's too bureaucratic. So the
empire won't change. The empire will not
emit its own mistakes. And quite
honestly, Iran because it's it's a still
country of 92 million people. It still
suffers from issues of mass,
organization, and death. And so it's
able to transform itself into an
energetic, open, and coherent society.
Then it will triumph over America. Right
now, Trump not releasing the Epstein
files, extremely unpopular war,
people becoming really disillusioned
with the Israel loyalty. I don't see the
American Empire being able to find
energy, openness, or cohesion in this
war. Absolutely not. Maybe in the
future, hopefully in the future, God
willing, we could have a leader that
could unite. As of now, I've never seen
the country more divided ever.
That is the fundamental question in this
war. Okay? Don't worry about America,
its technology,
>> gangster run America. That's exactly
what THE CCP WANTS, BRO.
>> Don't worry about the economy. Don't
worry about these things, okay? Just ask
yourself one question. Is Iran
transforming as a society? Are people
becoming much more motivated?
Are people in Iran learning from their
mistakes and innovating and becoming
resilient on the battlefield? There's a
really good example that Sulim brought
up yesterday in the space where in Syria
they
staged all these protests and the
internet stayed on for way too long.
But when Iran had the CIA MSAD
infiltrate the protests and tried to
spread propaganda about Hani, they
disabled the internet right away. They
didn't let it go on and drag out for a
long time. They shut it out. They were
learning from their neighbors.
>> Are the Iranians sticking together as a
people? Okay? Because if the answer is
yes to all three questions, then Iran
will win and America will lose. Okay?
Doesn't make sense. All right? So,
that's just a theory.
>> Hey, Socratic Ger, can you tell the
other one stop saying grapes, Nico?
>> So, let's um let's now talk specifically
about
America and Iran. Okay. So, America
will have three major advantages in this
war. Okay. These three adventures are
are of course technology.
>> He already said it. It's uh he said
technology, science. Let's see if I
learned
technology, science. They're more
advanced and they have mass
propaganda.
>> Okay. Well,
>> and money wealth.
These are the three major strengths of
the American empire, right? Technology
is just what you see every day, right?
The satellites that are able to
precision target these airplanes that
are the greatest war machines in the
world. Okay. So, America is home to the
greatest scientist, the most advanced
weaponry. And that's technology.
Propaganda means that America controls
information space. It controls the
internet. It controls the world's most
powerful media including the New York
Times, CNN, BBC.
It controls YouTube. It controls Google.
It controls information landscape.
America does not want you to
>> wait. Who controls all the Wait, who who
though? John
know something. It can hide it from you.
>> America can control the discourse. It
can control how you think about the
world. That's propaganda.
>> Think about this.
>> The last thing is money. Okay. And it's
first of all idea.
>> Wait, Chad, who controls the money, too?
I'm not going to do it. You know, it was
super eye opening yesterday. I was
speaking to that American soldier and he
didn't know why he was going into war. I
asked him, "Okay, what do you do? You're
an engineer." He said, "Yeah, I'm
engineering helicopters. I'm ready to I
might get deployed. I might have to
leave soon. They're making sure that
we're ready." And I said, "Wait, why are
you doing this war?" And he said, "Well,
I want to protect America." I'm like,
"Well, they just said Iran did not pose
an imminent threat to America. They just
said that." So, I didn't I didn't know.
He was about to leave. And I'm like,
"Wait, no, stay for a second. Why would
you not look this up before giving your
life to a cause? Why not take a second
to look at what the politicians are
saying in the news? It's not skitso
conspiracy.
The Secretary of War, the Secretary of
State, the president are saying Iran did
not pose a threat directly imminently."
And he's I don't know, bro. Imagine he
was just he was ready to die for
something he had no idea about. Just the
idea of America. Poor guy. He he was
well-intentioned but he had no clue what
he was saying.
The United States controls the US dollar
which is a s which is the reserve
currency of the world. And the United
States can print as much as much dollars
as it needs in order to win this war.
That's an infinite money.
>> What does that mean about reserve
currency of the world? It's a money.
>> Okay. And now and then it can use this
uh money to bribe people to fight this
war, right? It can it can pay for
mercenaries. It can bribe ethnic
minorities to rebel against the
government in Iran. It can bribe Iranian
officials to betray the the government.
>> So reserve currency definition means is
a foreign currency held in large
quantities by central banks and monetary
authorities as part of their foreign
exchange reserves primarily used for
international transactions, debt
servicing and managing US trades.
So it basically means it's the currency
of the central banks.
Okay. Okay.
So looking at these three things, you
would think that America is invincible,
right? But again, we need to think about
the loss asymmetry and recognize that
these advantages are also disadvantages.
All right? So let's discuss this
technology. Well, you know, if you have
the most advanced weaponry in the world,
you become lazy, arrogant, and dependent
on the technology, right? So, the
classic example of course is our school
where you have access to chat GBT,
right? And like you become smarter
because you have access to GT GP. No,
you become dumber because you become
lazy.
>> Dumber,
>> right? Same with technology. You would
think that with the most advanced
weaponry in the world, America would
become invincible. But instead, people
become the American um military becomes
too dependent on the on the technology.
It becomes too arrogant, too complacent.
Okay? It's like, well, you know, if we
if we're going to trouble, then we'll
just send in the Air Force and blow it
up.
>> It's kind of like the battle, the war of
the human soul versus the manufactured
soul. You know, artificial AI,
materialistic society, Peter Teal, chat,
GPT, advanced military weaponry versus a
couple of skits and some chest beating.
The spirit people united, united off of
a greater cause and the most advanced
military in the world getting people to
die for them because of propaganda.
That's what the war is.
>> Okay? So it leads to dependency
and this actually hampers innovation and
resilience in the battlefield and this
is what you need to win. Okay, you need
to be innovative and you need to be
resilient on the battlefield but because
of technology you become too lazy to
think for yourself. All right, so that's
one problem. propaganda. You would think
that, oh, America America control the
debate, therefore that's a huge
advantage. It's actually not an
advantage, guys. The reason why is that
in order for innovation and resilience
to happen, you need you need to have
open debate,
right? You need people to voice
dissenting opinions.
>> You know what's crazy, too? This is
happening right now. the people that I
disagree with and that have been very
publicly disagreeing of my anti-war
take. Kesan, he doesn't want to have a
conversation. Ben Shapiro won't debate.
Matt Walsh won't debate. Piers Morgan
won't do a debate. Matt Walsh will just
say, "Oh, you're low IQ. Okay, let's
let's have a conversation then. What's
up?" Well, I don't want to do it because
I Benpier obviously, you know, but Piers
Morgan, ask for a debate. Won't do it.
Same thing Oscar goal. Just publicly
challenge him to that conversation. I
don't think he's going to accept. I
mostly did that to show people that
you know why won't these people accept
not even it's not a debate but I was I
want to have that conversation because
we have disagreements and I think he is
falling for propaganda but so many of
these major voices they won't engage in
dialogue because they want to I think a
lot of them maybe they're not aware but
they do want to push things that are
lies and are propaganda and are untrue
and so they want to stay within that
echo chamber they want to echoing the
propaganda. I really do believe if
somebody is not willing to engage in
dialogue,
they are most likely pushing propaganda
and they're comfortable with it and they
like it.
But if you control the information
landscape, what you can do is censor and
that's what America's doing right now.
It's telling people to shut up and obey.
You're not allowed to point out that
this war is stupid and America can't win
this war otherwise you'll be kicked out.
Okay.
>> Yep. Yep. That's my goal right now. So
this means that there's really a lack of
rigorous debate within the American
government, within the American
military, within the American elite,
>> which of course will lead to hubris. It
will lead to bad decision-m. No one's no
one will point this out because they're
too too afraid of pissing off the
president and his people. So just shut
up and America will keep on making the
same mistakes over and over again. Okay.
We call this drinking your own cool way.
Okay.
>> Yeah. The cult ritual. They're basically
getting high on on their own supply is
some of the phrase that that we use. All
right.
>> Yeah. You think, okay, well that's this
is this is it, man. We just bl everyone.
We just brought the entire world and
>> stop being racist, bro. Kool-aid.
Kool-aid.
Cool. Really, dude? Bro, have show some
respect.
>> And uh we're good, right? The problem is
this. The problem is that if you bribe
people,
they're not going to fight for you,
right? Because all they all they want is
your money. So you bribe them, but then
but they'll probably take your money and
run away. Okay? Or they'll figure out
how to get more money out of you by
cheating you. So right now, the
Americans are going to fund these uh
militias and ethnic minorities and
opposition groups against Iran. Okay,
guess
>> a good major difference. the mass amount
of people that join the US Army, join
the military, they're doing it because
they want to BUY A DODGE CHARGER.
The people in Iran right now, the the
the want to do it because this is their
cause. They're doing this for jihad.
That's the some people are doing it for
currency because, you know, they want to
buy a ring for their Stacy.
These Shia is bro, they want to do it
for eternal paradise. That's a different
motivation. Why guys? These guys are
hustlers, right? They're not fighting
because um they want more freedom.
They're fighting because they want to
rip off the US government.
And so this money issue can be a problem
in the long term because the people
you're bribing, you can't even trust and
they're not that motivated to actually
win this war for you. They're actually
motivated to to scam you as much as
possible. And they could be actually a
problem in the long term because you're
putting so much resources into these
hustlers. Okay. All right. So, what this
means is that America has three major
problems. Okay. It has three major
problems. The first major problem is the
lack of political will.
And all this is saying is that the
American people don't want to fight this
war.
>> You have to die for Israel. Goyum, go
and die for the epsene regime. Doy, go
and fight for the epsene.
>> The American government doesn't even
know why they're fighting this war.
>> Facts.
>> No one cares. Okay. But for the
Iranians, it's a struggle of life and
death.
>> I just said that,
>> right? If America loses this war, they
just go home and forget about it. But
the Iranians lose this war, they all get
killed or they lose their country, they
lose their society, they lose their
civilization, they lose identity. Yeah,
they cannot afford to lose this war.
>> The only aspect of a whole or like a
religious battle here is they're just
trying to get people to genocide Muslims
because so much of Christianity in
America has been subverted to be
Zionists because like evangelicals in
the mega church are saying that God
bless those that bless state of Israel.
It's like the ultimate cause is turning
Christians into Zionists.
>> The first major problem that Americans
are facing is they don't have any
political will to fight this war, but
they're still fighting this war anyway.
Okay. The question of course is why?
Why? Why is this happening? This is
actually the most important question.
It's the most complicated. So, so, so
we'll save this for later. Okay. Second
is the idea of logistics and
manufacturing.
So, America is very good at fighting
short wars. Okay. The reason why is
they're advanced. They have the most
advanced weaponry, but they have
manufacturing issues because, as we
know, America shipped all its factories
to China. So we doesn't have any
factories doing that.
>> So yes, it has most advanced weaponry in
the world. But this weapon doesn't
doesn't do any good. You don't have any
ammunitions, right?
>> John comes on. Please pay less attention
to kick chat, bro.
>> Yeah, that's a good request. I think so.
I'm going to ignore the chat. I just had
to organize things last time. I don't
think I was paying attention that much,
but you have a point.
>> And you need factories for that. America
doesn't really have these factories. Now
I understand that America is trying is
trying to upgrade its manufacturing
capacity but it's kind of slow. All
right. So maybe 5 years from now it will
have manufacturing capac capacity to
fight this war but right now it doesn't.
So so that's another um major issue.
Okay. And then and then the last issue
of course is
casualties.
All right. America because it doesn't
have the political will to fight this
war cannot afford to lose soldiers on a
battlefield.
All right? So
it wants to minimize the death. It wants
to minimize battlefield losses because
if like a thousand tens of thousands
American soldiers are going home to
America dead in coffins, I guarantee you
because of lack of political will, the
American people will revolt. You have
protests. you won't have um a lot of
violence in the streets. It'll be like
the Vietnam uh era again.
>> I said it at the same exact time. I'm
the goat. I'm the best student in the
class. Amber, leave the room. Give me a
straight A. I need the gold star. I am
an honor student.
Top of the class. [ __ ] la. Suma cumlaude.
Pre-watch. E bro. Okay. Look at it. Look
at it. It was uploaded 3 hours ago. I've
been live for almost eight. All right.
Okay. So, um, yes, I understand that
America has technology, propaganda, and
money. But, as we discussed, these
aren't really advantages. And these
disadvantages are huge. The lack of
political will, the lack of
manufacturing, and the um lack of um of
America cannot afford to lose that many
soldiers in the battlefield. Okay. And
so this this situation now determines
how America will fight this war. And
we'll discuss this later on. Okay. All
right. Now let's talk about Iran.
Okay. So Iran has a lot of
disadvantages. Okay. But I I I want to
discuss right now there are three major
advantages that they need to emphasize
if they are to survive this war. All
right. The first is the idea of faith.
All right. So remember that the Iranians
are Shia
and as such it's a religion of martyrdom
of esquetology
of individual sacrifice for the greater
good. The Shia are not afraid to die.
And because their great religious
leader, the Adona Kinai was assassinated
by the Americans and Israel, they were
motivated to seek vengeance, to martyr
themselves for the greater good, to seek
eternal uh paradise. Okay, jihad.
>> All right, that's the first major
advantage. The second major advantage is
terrain.
And all this means is that
Iran is a mountain.
>> Bro, you're funny. Someone said jihad.
Jihad. Is that right? It's jihad, right?
I'm not I'm not going to say anything.
>> Is that
Iran is a mountainous country.
>> We know this.
>> It's huge. It's three times the size of
Iraq. Um, so it's very hard for America
to invade the country. In fact, most
analysts will will say will tell you it
is suicidal for the American military to
invade uh Iran. It is often fortress.
Okay, it's a fortress.
And the last issue is the last is
nationalism.
Okay.
All right.
So the Iranians are Persians
and the Persians go back 5,000 years. It
is one of the greatest civilizations in
human history. And as we discussed last
semester in the ancient world there were
three great civilizations, right? The
Jews, the Greeks, and the Persians.
And uh the Persian culture, it's vast,
it's beautiful, and it's deep. And
that's what gives the Iranian people a
lot of pride. Okay? So when they're
fighting, they're not just fighting for
the religion, not just fighting for the
homes, they're fighting for the entire
civilization that goes back 5,000 years.
Right? So these are the three major
advantages that the Iranians have. Okay.
Fate means that they're not
>> Well, there's a lot of disagreement
about that. I don't know if that's an
advantage because a lot of Iranians they
there there is some sort of sentiment
within Iran that they were conquered by
the Arabs that they lost their
Zorastrian Persian culture and they
became and maybe that's why so much of
the the Shia division happened with the
Sunnis maybe the Shia started to
differentiate between the Arab Sunnis
>> not afraid to die for what they believe
in terrain means that the Americans have
a hard problem in vain.
>> I know this advant I know this is an
advantage not oh yeah yeah but he's
going to get to the disadvantages
>> the country uh nationalism means that
the Americans have a hard problem
invading the country uh nationalism
means that the people of Iran know what
they're fighting for. All right so again
remember ebing that it seems like an
advantage can be a disadvantage as well.
All right. So,
let's go over what the problems are.
With faith, you might have an issue of
blindness,
okay? Or zealatry
where you're not afraid to die, but that
means that you're not thinking
strategically, okay?
>> You just want to be smart.
>> Maybe you're going to waste too many
soldiers on the battlefield. They're
brave, but they're kind of stupid as
well,
>> right? So you might have an issue where
Iran is not using the optimal um
strategy because their soldiers are not
afraid of death. And we're already
seeing that where where the Americans
have already blown up and destroyed the
Iranian navy. Now any told you that the
first thing Americans would do is go
destroy the Iranian navy. So you should
probably not use the navy or hide the
navy or blow the navy yourself. Okay?
Because you want to avoid as many
casualties as possible. But they didn't
do that. and the Americans have now
destroyed the Iranian navy, right? So
that's the issue of faith. Terrain,
yeah, it's a fortress, but it can also
be a prison, right? Where you're just
sort of stuck there. And because it's a
mountainous region, it doesn't have that
many resources. So Americans can
actually disrupt your water supply,
disrupt your electricity,
>> okay, and cause general poverty and
hardship.
>> Who studied from yesterday? What's that
lake called?
>> For your people. Okay. And then
nationalism. Yes, Persia is a great
culture, but remember that Iran is a
ethnically diverse country. In fact,
only 50% of the population of Iran are
Persians. Others are different
minorities. Okay. All right. So, um you
have then ethnic divisions,
right?
Okay. So looking at this now we know
exactly
what the American strategy will be.
Basically the strategy will be to
inflict as many casualties as possible
on the Iranians. All right to kill as
many people as possible.
Destroy the infrastructure of Iran of
Iran so the people don't have enough
water, electricity, food to survive.
Okay. And the third of course is to
create as much ethnic tension in the
country as possible by arming and
encouraging and bribing ethnic groups to
rebel against central government in
Tran. Right? Okay. But again
what the law of symmetry asymmetry tells
us is that the empire ultimately is not
as flexible and open and dynamic as its
enemy. Okay. the weaker person is going
to engage in much more self-reflection,
self-debate
than the empire. Okay? Because empire
will become arrogant. And so ultimately
Iran should triumph over America. And in
fact, what's going to happen is that
this strategy that America will use
against the Iranians will lead to
Iranians becoming much more energetic,
open, and cohesive.
Okay. So, let's look at let's look at
let's look at the American strategy
specifically.
>> Good lesson so far.
>> All right. So this is an ethnic map of
Iran. Okay.
>> Certain things that you will see is how
divide the country is. Yeah. The
Persians are in the center, but people
you want to watch are the Kurds.
>> Okay. The Kurds and the um Azaris.
You guys saying you're caught in 4K
pre-watching. Like why? What do you mean
caught?
If I watched the lecture twice, I would
want you to think that because I'm
trying to learn more and become more
well-versed in the subject. I'm not
caught. That would be if that were true,
I would be happy that I watched the
lecture twice. That means that I'm
paying more attention and I'm trying to
learn more. What do you think that
you're exposing? Oh my god, Sneo's
trying to learn
and the bollocks.
Okay, these are the three major problem
areas for Iran and it's always been the
case. Remember the Persians are in the
middle. So the Bollocks are first of all
Sunni Muslims.
As we discussed last class, the Sunnis
and the Shia have never really gotten
along well together. They have different
I mean the same religion.
>> Well, not anymore. Not anymore. Keep
your division for Keep that in Hibb.
We're going to keep the umah united
inshallah.
Okay, I'm beating my chest. I'm beating
my chest. I'm not saying yah Ali. I'm
not invoking dead people, but I'll beat
my chest. I don't care if that makes you
upset. I'm going to be bleeding at the
chest. Oh, that won't hurt. That won't
hurt. Ya Allah, not y. All right. We're
not praying to graves. We're not praying
on stones.
And we love Aisha.
uh Islam, but they have different belief
systems that's led to a lot of conflicts
in the past. It's almost like the
Catholics and the Protestants. Okay? And
so the Bullocks have been trying to
rebel against Iranians for a long time.
I guarantee you that there are already
Israeli and American special forces
embedded in this area. Okay.
>> What's this called again? The Bullocks.
How do you spell this?
>> The Bullock.
>> Bullick. They want to encourage as much
civil conflict as possible, but they
also want to prepare to grasp up the
possibility for a ground invasion of
America. Okay? So, they would need a um
forward operating base and this area
could be a very good place for a
beginning of land of of a land invasion.
Then you over here you have the Kurds.
Okay, the Kurds are another minority
that seeks national sovereignty. And
right now what's happening is that the
Americans and Israelis are bombing this
area heavily and they're targeting
police stations. Why? Because they're
trying to reduce and eliminate
opposition so that they can arm the
Kurds and have them come into this area
and and threaten um Iran. What's also
happening is that in Iraq
there are these Sunni
uh groups, okay, that the Americans are
uh basically bribing and arming and
they're basically fanatics. Okay,
they're ISIS and what the Americans want
to do is send them into uh Iran to cause
as much problem as possible. Okay. Then
you over here you have Ashban.
Ashan
it is a
>> look at you guys. Classic Sunni traders.
Really? Classic Sudi tra. No ISIS is is
CIA. That's not representative. Stop.
Stop. Stop it.
Actually
it is a independent country. What's
really odd is that the majority of
ethnic uh Azaris are actually in Iran.
66% are in the country 40% are in the
country of Azro which means that from
the perspective of the Azrajani people
people this war could be an opportunity
to reunite
the people okay and create a greater
ajan. So these are the three prong areas
that you have to watch as this war
develops over the next few weeks, over
the next few months. Okay. So we already
know what the American strategy will be
because we've seen it in Libya, in Syria
before. Okay. So what is the strategy?
All right. So again, the strategy is to
both attack without, okay, from outside
and inside as well.
>> Inside. So what you're going to do is
this. You're going to arm these people
in embed special forces into these
interesting groups to lead them and
provide air cover so they have a clear
path into Iran and are able to eliminate
opposition. Okay.
>> Divide and conquer.
>> So now you're attacking from without
attacking from within means to cause as
much pain and suffering in the interior
of Iran as possible. All right. And how
do you do that? Well, you do that
through um decapitation. Okay, let's go
over the strategies.
Okay, decap decapitation.
Okay, and what you're doing is you're
removing
>> the elite. Okay, or what we call command
and control.
Okay, you're basically limiting the
capacity of Iran to govern itself, to
have a leadership, to have an elite,
right? Command and control. Okay. So
that's the first strategy. Second
strategy
is um
um area open bar. Okay. Aeros supremacy.
So again, America has the most advanced
airplanes in the world. And the way that
it's using it airplanes is to destroy as
much military installation as possible,
but it's also engaging in acts of
sabotage. Okay? So what they're doing is
they're cover bombing.
Okay. So they're cover bombing Iran.
Okay.
>> Why are they doing that heavily?
>> Um they're doing soft targeting.
Soft targeting. Soft targeting means
instead of attacking military
installations, you attack hospitals.
Why? Because you're degrading the
capacities. Sorry, you're degrading the
state's capacity to rejuvenate itself,
to be resilient.
>> Can you please Jen, can you please stop
standing in front of the nose pearl?
The last thing is something called a
soft targeted. Okay.
>> Double tap.
>> Double tap is this. Okay. Uh and it's
really illegal uh or against um
international law. What you do is this.
You attack a place,
>> right? You kill some people
>> and then people try to come and help the
people who are injured and they could be
like um doctors, it could be e emergency
personnel, it could be relatives, right?
And then you strike again to create as
much as many civilian cases as possible.
>> Can you move?
>> Right. And the entire idea is to create
as much fear and anxiety in people as
possible so that they lose the capacity
to resist. Right? And the last thing you
do um and so the and the last thing of
course is to um arm and bribe
insurgents.
Okay. So these are the three main
pillars of the American strategy and you
will see this over the next few weeks.
The problem with this is that when you
do these three things, you're not
actually hurting the Iranians. You're
actually helping them. Because remember,
the law of asymmetry states that
whichever group is able to to create
energy, openness, and cohesion will win.
And guess what, guys? This American
strategy is going to create a more
energetic, more open, and more cohesive
>> what society. All right, let me show you
how. All right, the calcation.
We just said that one major problem for
America is elite over production, right?
Well, with the capation,
what you're doing is you're solving this
problem for the Iranians, right? Before
the huge problem for the Iranians were
you have too many leaders
and they all have their own stupid
opinion and they all want to lead this
war, right? But by killing so many
leaders, you allow for more mobility,
for for more meritocracy, right? You're
solving the problem of overp production
for the radiance. That's a huge huge
bonus, guys. Okay, so um the leadership
will become much more lean, much more
mean, much more determined, and much
more strategic. Okay,
>> strategic.
>> That's number one. Number two, a
supremacy.
>> The Bible. Well, when you do this to
people, you cover bomb terrain, you're
creating more cohesive society.
Why? Because the major conflict in Iran
for many decades was the conflict
between the urban areas and the rural
areas. The rural areas were very
religious, very poor, very backward. And
the urban areas were educated, secular,
and progressive. Okay? And so there's
this huge conflict that led to a lot of
riots, a lot of protests in uh Iran. But
when you cover the cities which are the
main source of of of support for you
know progressive western. So, so far US
in five, six days, six, seven days, they
already did these two. Decapitation,
they're killing all the leaders. Number
two, aerial supremacy headset is
literally said that they're going to be
looking up at all the death and
destruction raining upon them. And all
the bombing is happening right in the
capital, a place with a lot of
civilians. They're just carpet bombing
innocent people because they can and
they want to go flex in a White House at
it. Epic Fury
>> policies. You make them united with the
rural areas. Okay, does that make sense?
The Indian people no longer see themsel
each other as enemies. They see the
Americans, the Israelis as enemies. You
create a much more cohesive society
which are who are willing to fight
together and that's a problem. Okay. All
right. The last thing, yes, you are
arming the assertions, the bulocks, the
Kurds, the Zaris. Okay. That's fine.
Look at these. Buy the Dow. Epic Fury.
Sexual casting. Yeah, [ __ ] Buy the Dow.
Epic Fury. When you buy the Dow, don't
look at the Epstein files. Buy the Epic
Dow.
>> Problem with this is that you're now
>> activating galvanizing Persian
nationalism.
Right. For the longest time, the Persian
national identity was suppressed by the
theocracy because they want to create a
more, you know, they want to create a
grand religion that unites all
ethnicities. When you turn the other
minorities against the Iranians, then
the Persian people have to come together
and remember their history, celebrate
your identity.
>> Yeah.
>> And this is the key. Okay.
>> Yeah. Once the Persian people
>> Well, well, a lot of the Persians in the
West right now, they're just they saw
their country getting bombed and they
strip naked to go on Instagram and start
dancing to kids dying. That didn't
happen to so many of the Persians like,
"Oh, Islam, they ruined or they ruined
the Persian Empire." They go to America
and open an Only Fans account to
celebrate Hani being assassinated.
>> Are able to activate their long-lasting
memories. Go back in the past and
remember the greatness. They come
together as an energetic, open, and
cohesive society. Okay?
So, yes, the Americans have this
strategy that worked in Libya and Syria
and other places, but it's not going to
work in Iran. In fact, it's going to do
the opposite in Iran.
Okay? And then you're like, well, why
don't the Americans not do this? And I
already told you because it's an empire.
Okay? It doesn't care about Iran. It
cares about itself. And so it's sort of
stuck with this policy because remember
it's trying to win this war as quickly
as possible because it doesn't have the
manufacturing capacity to fight this war
for a long time. It's trying to reduce
as many civilian sorry it's trying to
reduce as many casualties among its
soldiers as possible because the
Americans don't have the political will
to fight this war. Americans trying to
win this war cheaply and fast. If it
doesn't then Americans a lot of trouble.
Okay, does that make sense guys? Father,
>> let me now um conclude sorry let let me
now discuss the Iranian strategy. Okay.
So um what the Americans are using is a
classic strategy called siege warfare.
Okay.
And so what the Iranians are going to do
is they're going to respond with a
classic strategy called guerilla
warfare.
>> Okay. And gorilla warfare guys is just
as simple as hideandsek.
>> Yeah. Vietnam.
>> All right. So, you come bomb me with all
everything you have. I'll just hide in
my mountains. And then when you leave,
what what I'm going to do? I'm going to
attack your uh GCC countries. I'm going
to lock drones, rockets at you. I'm I'm
lock um rockets at Israel. Okay. I I
don't have I don't have to strike that
hard. I just have to make I just have to
be a pain in the ass. Okay. Because
>> Why are you guys saying warfare?
>> Oh, guerilla warfare. Yeah. Hilarious,
guys. Hilarious, guys.
>> Then what happens is you're forced to
come back and bomb the living hell out
of me. But guess what? That's how my
mouth is again. It's hide and seek.
Okay? So, Iran can do this for years and
years and years. But again, remember,
America is forced to win this war as
fast as possible because there's no
political will. They don't have
manufacturing capacity and they uh don't
want it uh they don't want that many
casualties and economic damage. Okay?
Does that make sense, guys?
>> All right. So, that's all I going to do.
I mean, it's just going to be a pain in
the ass. Okay? In the ass. It's trying
to create as much economic damage as
possible. is trying to create as much
fear as possible, right? Which will
force America to attack the
>> Okay, so update just saying Alai John
just got hit. Say wala say oh god by
john did it get hit
by john just get hit oh wow just a drone
struck knocked chiban's airport in John
who was it
was it Iran
If it was a drone, this is the
This is Iran's equipment usually, right?
Definitely Iran. Yeah, I know. They
could have
Could it be MSAD pretending to be Iran?
Let's see. This interesting timing.
Aaban Johnson said it will not allow its
airspace airspace to be used against
Iran. Okay, that's big.
Abjan's former foreign ministry says,
"We strongly condemn the drone attacks
launched from Iranian territory. This
attack on Azan violates international
law and increases regional tensions.
Abajan reserves the right to take
appropriate response measures." Oh.
Oh man.
Is it a false flag?
Who did it though?
Iranian kamicazi drone.
This guy, bro. Mario Defall likes to
play both sides. Playing both side is
really sided with Epstein regime.
Targeted for the first time by Iran as a
drone hits.
US looks like it's gearing up for a long
war, possibly 100 days or more.
yeah about Johnny government supplies
Israel.
Should I tweet something?
Iranian suicide drones are striking.
Well, why why why would is this the same
reason that Iran is attacking the GCC
countries? Because Aabaijan supports
Israel.
Wait, let me finish the lecture and then
we can hop in the space.
>> When question is this, will America
launch a ground invasion? Okay, because
if it does, then
um they've lost the war. Okay. All
right. Because look look at look at
Iran, okay? Mountains and mountains,
deserts. It is impossible to occupy this
country.
All right? It's impossible to invade.
And what the want to do is be so such a
pain in the ass to commit so much guilt
warfare that America is forced to invade
okay from over here and from over here
and from over here and from over here
and then eventually uh but the problem
is that America doesn't have doesn't
have the resources the will manufacture
capacity to fight this war. Okay.
>> Yeah, you're right. This war is going to
be over in 48 hours. Retweet and come
back when this war is over. Dubai my
bugi in Dubai. My yacht in Dubai. I'm
gonna drive my Bugatti right into the
Iranians. You can't spell Iran without
Iran from the song that made me
apologize.
>> Doesn't make sense. All right. So now
you're like, "Okay, I understand all
this.
>> Sneo did it. Sneak's I ran, but why the
hell is this war happening then?"
Like, if I can tell you this, okay, I'm
sure that their generals can tell them
this as well. I'm sure that they know
that this was the case. In fact, for
years,
>> you know what's funny? Like we have a
lot of ethnic divisions just like Iran.
There's different ethnic groups in love
speech. There are we have a bajani here.
We have brown clowns. We have the
Persian, you know, we have different
factions. Shia, Sunni, all this stuff.
The one thing that the chat is always
united on is like just dunking on top go
saying [ __ ] things over and over
again.
Everyone unites on that. Because that's
when nobody will try to rage bait me
either. And Jang's getting called by
Msad right now.
>> America has been playing between
>> top G. [ __ ] I am Top G. Shut up.
>> Bait Iran. And for years, the general
was like, "No, that's suicidal. Let's
not do this." Okay. So, why is this
happening?
And unfortunately, we don't know because
the administration is not telling us. At
first, Trump is like, "Oh, because the
nuclear talks didn't go well." We know
for a fact that the Iranians were
willing to agree to all terms of the
Americans. And then Marco Rubio, who's
who's the secretary of state, he came
out yesterday and he said something
really more.
>> He said that America was not threatened
by Iran. They were only threatening
Israel. Then the other woman, I forget
her name, she said that Trump had a
feeling that Iran would pose a threat
and so he bombed them first. It was like
he was just getting a vibe. Trump was
getting like a vibe that they'd be
attacked based on facts. So he did it.
They just keep on Nobody is on the same
page.
>> All right. He said that. Why did we
attack Iran? Because we heard the
Israelis were going to attack first. And
then Iranians were going to respond by
by attacking both the Israelis and us,
the Americans. And therefore, we have to
preempt the Israelis by attacking first.
That's just [ __ ] Okay. Right. So
they don't they don't know why they're
doing this. But there has to be a
reason, right? Okay. Well, a clue is
this. The clue is this. The right. So,
they don't they don't know why they're
doing this, but they have to be a
reason. Right. Right. So, they don't
they don't know by attacking first.
Dang.
>> Let's just [ __ ] it. Okay.
>> Let's just [ __ ]
>> Right. So, the clue is this. The clue is
this. The soldiers are being asked, the
American soldiers are being asked to
fight this war. And again, no one told
us why this war is happening, but
there's reporting that the generals are
telling the soldiers, "This is a war
for
>> holy
>> Jesus."
>> Yes. Yes. Yes. I just covered this. Yes.
>> Yes. Pete Hex is of the belief that this
is a crusade that Jesus shined a light
on Trump to bless Israel.
war
to
create the second coming of Jesus. Okay,
this is um John Larson and he's writing
this on on substant. Okay, US troops
were told Iran war is for Armageddon,
the return of Jesus. What is this? Okay,
so um so sorry. So
>> get into it. Get into it.
>> Some soldiers who are not Christians
were told that there's a war for Jesus
and like wait a minute, we're not we're
not Christians. We're Muslims or we're
atheists. Why are we fighting this war?
And so they filed a complaint about the
speech. Okay,
>> I just read this
>> and we're going to read a part of
>> Well, well, I'm ahead of the curve,
chat. We read this whole article
yesterday. That's how on top of things I
am. The best war coverage in the game in
the streaming industry is me. Throw that
[ __ ] Stop playing with me, man.
>> Email that the soldiers who are
desenting sent to some other people to
complain about this. Okay, so um I could
could you read, please?
We and you know I didn't even prepare
reading this article. Amber's going to
read it and fumble it. I found this
during the stream and I was able to
decipher that this was an article worth
reading. Do I really read articles like
that on stream? Not much unless it's
really necessary. And I uncovered
with my iikido and my high IQ. I don't
read readings gay. But I decided that
this is like Megan Fox with a dick. And
I would read this article cuz Hulk Hogan
with the [ __ ] or Megan Fox with the
dick. And that was this article.
>> I am a NCO rank withheld in our unit.
>> Okay, I can't do it. I'm an NCO rank
with held in our unit. This morning, our
commander opened up to combat readiness
status briefing by urging us to not be
afraid as to what is happening with our
combat operations in Iran right now. He
urged to tell us our troops to tell our
troops that this was all part of God's
divine plan. And he specifically
referenced numerous citations out of the
book of Revelation referring to
Armageddon and the imminent return of
Jesus Christ. That was the entire
monologue of the stream. The whole intro
of the stream was about this. The
evangelical Christian movement, the
obligatory nature of this religion where
they are telling people that Christians
must bless the state of Israel. We saw
the pastor that said that Jesus was a
Zionist.
He said that President Trump was has
been anointed by Jesus to light the
signal fire in Iran to cause Armageddon
and mark his return to Earth. Jesus
Trump has been anointed by Jesus to
light the signal fire in Iran.
This morning, our commander opened up
the combat.
>> Joey Amber is a high schooler. This is a
high school
>> operations in afraid. That's what it
tells us. Don't lose no war. Okay.
Right. Keep going.
>> He urged us to tell our troops that this
was all part of God's divine.
>> Kind of weird.
>> Wait a minute here. Wait a minute. God's
divine plan. God's not the one ordering
them to fight this war. It's Trump or or
the American military. Okay, this is
kind of weird. Keep on going. And he
specifically referenced numerous
citations out of the book of revelation
referring to Armageddon and the imminent
return of Jesus Christ. He said that
President Trump has been anointed by
Jesus to light the signal fire in Iran
to cause Armageddon and mark his return
to earth.
>> Oh my god. President Trump, the fire in
Iran, it's all part of a grand plan to
destroy the world that Jesus will
return. What is this crap? Okay, keep on
going.
>> He had a big grin on the fa on his face.
Okay. He's happy about this guy.
>> Why does he make her read it when he
just interrupts her? Like he's like,
"Okay, Abra, go ahead." And he has, "Oh,
the Bible.
>> THE WORLD IS ENDING."
>> YEAH. COME ON.
>> When he said all of this, which made his
message seem even more crazy, our
commander would probably be described as
a Christian first supporter. He has been
this way for a very long time and makes
it clear that he desires all of us under
him to become just like him as a
Christian. But what he did this morning
was so toxic and over
>> I want to hear that again about I was
writing a note ready or what
>> he had
>> to destroy the world so Jesus will
return. What is this crap? Okay, keep
going.
>> What did he say to the right? This has
got to be the thumbnail. Well, he's one
of my favorite professors ever. Wait,
what did he
about this? THE WORLD IS ENDING.
>> YEAH.
>> YES. Jesus has a knight and a light a
light on Trump to bomb Iran. Yeah.
The end of the world to die FOR JEWISH
SUPREMACIST IN EPSTEIN. HOCKEY.
YEAH.
Don't look at the Epstein files. The
Dell is up.
>> He had a big
>> Yeah.
>> On his face.
>> He's happy about this, guys. The world
is ending.
>> I didn't play it.
[ __ ] AMERICA.
HECK YEAH.
WE'RE GOING TO BOMB ALL OF THE MUSLIM
AMERICA. EPIC FURY.
THEY'RE GOING TO NIGHT A LIGHT ON
TRUMPY.
[ __ ] YEAH. ARMAGEDDON. WE'RE GONNA KILL
MUSLIMS.
YEAH.
>> SO, LAST TIME, last time, last time. was
the best. Okay, I'm sorry people
watching.
>> He's happy about this, guys. The world
is ending.
>> YEAH.
>> ALL RIGHT. SORRY.
>> When he said all of this, which made his
message seem even more crazy, our
commander would probably be described as
a Christian first supporter. He's been
this way for a very long time and makes
it clear that he
>> Why is she like Why is she reading like
that? He made it a very long time that
he was going to end the world and be a
really good business.
He has been this way for a very long
time and makes it clear that he desires
all of us under him to become just like
him as a Christian. But what he did this
morning was so toxic right
>> all of us was so toxic and over
>> toxic and it's just like
>> lying that it shocks many of us in
attendance at the ops.
>> What the heck is wrong with you, dude?
Bro, Mazy just said, are you kidding me?
Bat soup reading.
>> Bat soup reading. You're like I'm gonna
Okay, five minute timeout. written in
this brief brieving besid besides
myself. I am reaching out.
>> This is basically how they're getting
people to fight the war. Have you seen
this?
>> I'll watch it after the look so I don't
get copyrighted. Hold on.
>> The MRF on behalf of 15 fellow troops. I
know you asked me about the religious
views of our group who has requested
help from the MRFF.
>> Chad, you want a hot tub stream with
Amber? Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
One of the others is Jewish.
>> Okay. Amber. Amber. Amber. Wait, who's
Jewish? Yeah. Jewish. Okay.
>> And one is one is Muslim. I don't know
the religious or non-religious status
for the other three at this time.
>> Okay. So, what is happening is that
there are some crazy Christians in the
American military, in American
government. Okay.
>> She's 18.
>> That want to use this.
>> It was a stupid joke, dude. Like,
obviously, this is a stupid joke. war
to end the world
to force Jesus to return.
That is why this war is happening. Yeah.
I'm not saying I'm not saying that this
is a reason why, but I'm saying like
this is a possibility. Okay.
>> You know what's funny about it?
>> It's US and Israel, but Israel has a
completely different Messiah than Jesus.
It's so funny. Look at them all. They're
trying to fire trying to get Trump to
anoint a fire
so he could light up Iran. And the
people that we struck Iran for, they
have the Antichrist as the Messiah. They
literally reject Jesus.
>> All religious leaders that support Trump
because they see him as Messiah. They
they see him as this as this great
>> Amber, turn up your phone who will cause
the time of Christianity and the return
of Jesus. And that's a possibility as to
why this war is being fought. Okay?
Because quite honestly, there's no other
reason. It's hard for me to come up with
another reason. Okay?
All right. So, this is something that we
will look at as we go along. What is
this crap? What is Christian Zionism?
Why would they think that this war in
the Middle East will cause the return of
Jesus? Okay, we'll we'll discuss this
later on,
but I wanted to but now it leads us to
another problem which is our entire
class is on game theory. Right guys,
this is kind of weird because
what this suggests is that religion
is more important. Okay, so what's the
point of game theory if people don't
play by game theory? if all if they're
just religious fanatics.
All right? And the answer is this. And
the answer is
it's still game theory. But the problem
is that
what you think
of the game that you think they're
playing is not the game they're playing.
The reward that you think they want want
is not the reward they that they want.
Okay? We think in terms of material
things. Okay? So money, resources,
power. We think that the war is being
fought over these things.
>> These
>> and it's not.
All right. The grand secret, the grand
reveal of the semester, of this course
is this.
>> The real power, the real currency in the
world is not money.
It is human consciousness.
>> No, he gets it so close and then he just
goes back to Buddhism. The real word is
eternal paradise. Human consciousness is
not God. Jang, it's okay. You can
believe what he believes. We have a
difference of opinion. It's like it all
comes down to your brain. Uh
no but uh cook
or basically attention.
Okay, this is this is it guys. Okay,
once you understand this idea, you
understand everything. But this is a
hard idea to understand. So so I I'll
need some time to actually explain this.
All right.
>> Yeah. Basically, he he explained it
before many times. He thinks that
everybody has a divine nature that's
within and that he was talking about
this about the, you know, the hidden
truth of Christianity that Eve was
actually talking to Satan when she
thought she was talking to God and that
it was inverted and that a person
created the God that people worship in
Christianity and that this universe is
actually created by a man who created
God because God is within and that's the
hidden secret.
that monotheistic religions worship a
fake demon when God is really within us
all along. This war is being fought to
control the consciousness of the human
race because it is our consciousness
that creates reality itself. That's the
source of all wealth.
>> See, he just said it. He consciousness
creates reality of it. No, God created.
You can't something can't create itself.
That doesn't make sense. I'm not even
going to write that note.
>> All power in this world. Okay, that's
why this is happening. In other words,
>> he's saying he's right. Are you a
Gnostic? Are you a Buddhist? What are
you,
America? [ __ ] yeah. Oh, he's trolling.
He's Wang half. Okay, this guy's a rage.
Does anybody believe this or No. How
many people in the chat? No, don't
troll. I actually want to get a poll.
How many people believe in what he's
saying right now? manifestation and that
stuff.
God is consciousness. Okay. Are you
stupid? That wasn't even rage, mate.
This guy actually believes it.
No, God is the almighty, all merciful,
the all knowing,
the creator of the heavens and earth,
the the creator.
>> This is a war not just for Iran. This is
a war not just for the Middle East. It
is a war for the soul of humanity. This
is what's happening, guys. All right?
This is what World World War II is.
World War II is meant to be the last and
final war of all human history. Because
whoever wins this war will control the
very soul of human existence for all of
eternity. Okay? That is the end game.
And I know this is hard to understand,
but as we go along, I will explain this
to you. Okay, that is the grand secret
behind the world. Everything that you
believe, everything that you see today,
it's all an illusion.
The reality, the truth is
>> that consciousness is a source of all
power of reality itself. And so this is
a war.
>> No,
>> for you said consciousness is the source
of everything.
But then what created? You just keep how
you keep on going. So what created
consciousness?
I don't know how much I should talk
about that with Jen. We have an
interview on March 8th in a couple of
days. I think I want to stick to Iran
war, but I I do really want to talk.
It's super interesting, especially after
the last couple lectures where we
learned about what he thinks about the
truth about monotheism. I think he was
specifying Christianity, but he also
could think it's about in Islam, too,
because we also have the story of Adam
and Eve.
So, what created God? Same thing. No,
no, no, it's not the same thing. God is
the almighty creator that does not exist
within the plane that we live in in the
reality that we are aware of. God is the
all- knowing. God is not mortal. God is
greater than all of us here. Thank you,
Wally, for the sub. Talk to him off
stream. I know, but that's such a good
conver. We could talk on stream, too. I
mean, look, last conversation we had was
three hours. If we have three hours,
hopefully we do. I really want to get
into this stuff especially with World
War II esquetology because because I've
watched his lectures and we also had a
previous conversation a lot of it was
about geopolitics. We didn't speak about
God.
Would you guys prefer that when we talk
should I go more about philosophy or
more about geopolitics?
What would you prefer I focus the
conversation on? It's going to be
interesting. Obviously, we're going to
touch on both, but what would you prefer
as the main focus? Geopolitics or
philosophy,
man. It's really divided.
It's like Persia in here. Geo or
philosoph.
Yeah, I know. Obviously, I'm going to do
both, but there's going to be a ma like
a main direction of the conversation.
I think a lot of people are saying geo
geopolitics.
That's probably the most viral. But
what's more impactful is philosophy.
Geopolitics is clip farming is
short-term. Philosophy will last
forever.
Polls don't work, dude. Give it up. The
polls on kick don't work.
Human consciousness. It's a war for the
very soul of humanity.
Okay. Any questions?
All right. I I will see you guys next
week.
>> Great lecture.
Jang to go.